just got a motorola press conference and
there's a pretty interesting stuff from
there there are two new smartphones
there's the motorola atrix and the droid
bionic they're both dual-core
smartphones meaning they have a
dual-core processors that can handle
simultaneous task more quickly than
single core processors there were also
both working on the 4g network there was
also a tablet called the motorola xoom
running the latest Android operating
system or the next generation one called
Android Honeycomb Motorola didn't have a
product to show today but they said it
was going to be a pretty big deal in the
next few months